so one of the very first side quests
that you receive in God of War now you
don't actually get to finish until close
to the end of the game is about the
Dwarven king known as mode signal we
learn in game that mode signal was a son
of Ivaldi and he was regarded as a dwarf
in king who ruled over the regions of
Vegard and Connors Guard
it doesn't take long before we find out
about the Kings obsession with creating
the legendary armor known as that the
vague Wrath decode the armor itself was
believed to provide ultimate protection
but in order for it to be constructed
three rare ingredients would have to be
collected and so mote signa had his
people hunt and capture a variety of
extremely powerful and rare creatures
including several dragons as he believed
harnessing their power to be the key in
his desperate search the king would
collect two of the ingredients needed
but as his obsession of a came him the
search for the third it's what drove him
insane
in their search crater Senate race to
eventually stumble across the withered
corpse of the king and was shown a
journal entry containing the details to
his story when most significant king he
was good and just but he soon began to
have dreams of his people being slain
and that is the reason he forced him to
hunt these powerful creatures he
captured three dragons and harvested
their fury and he then harvested the
screams of innocent people killing them
to make the army that he believed would
save them all it would be those innocent
people that would return as hell walkers
and exact their revenge on the Dwarven
King shortly after we find another
journal entry this time contained in the
last words of my signal tragic that my
failure becomes apparent as a life flows
out of me the gods came to me as I slept
and demanded retribution for my father's
actions in nil Fame my people they who
entrusted me to keep them safe every
damn night visions of them mangled by
all manner of Beast only I could protect
them and only through building the de
Vega a seeker I captured every deadly
beast I could find and set to build in
the myth the dreams were very clear
about the dragon's fury and the screams
of the innocent though many were
sacrificed capturing the dragons and the
innocent screams of far worse than I'd
ever imagined all of it was for the
greater good of the third ingredient my
dreams are vague ultimate sacrifices all
they would say I had hoped for fit in my
morality during this damn search would
be enough now I see that it was my own
sacrifice that was required
like my father before me I've been such
a fool most significant when this story
begins were led to believe that mode
signal was some kind of evil king or
tyrannical leader but by the end we see
that he was essentially paying for the
sins of his father he valued nothing
more than the protection of his people
and he blindly placed his faith in the
legend of the de Vega ethic oh the army
he believed to keep them all safe a
gamble that would ultimately cost no
signal if-- and many of the people that
resided in his kingdom in God of War he
was the son of Ivaldi but in Norse
mythology many regard moat signior to be
the father of all dwarves resided in the
realm of need of a layer moat signal was
not fathered by another dwarf he was
instead created by Odin and his two
brothers from the body of Amir when he
was slain it said that the dwarves
originally took the form of a maggot and
they were later given a rough humanoid
appearance and human-like intelligence
attributes that would be inherited by
all dwarves to come the story of what
signera is definitely quite interesting
and the idea of a dwarf king who falls
victim to the temptation of a great
legend and is weighed down by the burden
of keeping his people safe is very
reminiscent to the Hobbit and much of
Tolkien's work who himself was quite
heavily influenced by Norse mythology if
you enjoyed this video and you have any
thoughts and ideas should like to share
about the dwarf king then let me know in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained